-"La montagne, ça vous gagne."
Ce slogan colle parfaitement
à mon invitée.
Ancienne monitrice de ski,
c'est pour défendre
son village de montagne
qu'elle s'est engagée en politique.
Un combat
pour ces territoires enclavés
qu'elle mène
en tant que députée.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Marie-Noël Battistel.
-Bonjour.
-Vous êtes députée socialiste,
mais à vos débuts,
c'était pas pour défendre les idées
d'un parti
que vous vous êtes engagée.
L'élément déclencheur est un drame
qui a frappé votre village
de La Salle-en-Beaumont,
en Isère.
C'était dans la nuit
du 7 au 8 janvier 1994.
-Voici ce qui reste de la partie
haute de La Salle-en-Beaumont,
200 habitants,
c'était la maison du boulanger.
Voici où cette nuit
s'est arrêtée la nationale 85,
la route Napoléon, qui relie,
- ou plutôt reliait -
Grenoble à Gap.
-C'est la montagne qui est tombée.
C'est tout.
-Deux couples
manquent toujours à l'appel.
Leur maison était là
avant le passage d'un mur de boue
de 30 m de haut et 200 m de large.
-Il y a eu quatre décès
dans ce glissement de terrain.
C'est ce drame-là
qui a déclenché
votre envie de vous engager
en politique ?
-Oui, tout à fait.
C'est finalement
un événement tragique
dans cette commune,
où j'habitais déjà
depuis plusieurs années,
qui a déclenché mon envie
d'aller plus loin.
Je militais beaucoup
dans le monde associatif,
à cette époque.
Evidemment,
on s'est engagé
pour aider les sinistrés,
puisque quatre personnes
sont décédées,
et 10 familles
ont perdu leur maison,
il fallait les accompagner.
J'ai vite vu les limites
du monde associatif,
des actions associatives,
pour finalement, ensuite,
reconstruire,
passer à la reconstruction
du village.
C'est comme ça
que j'ai décidé de m'engager
dans l'élection municipale de 1995,
l'année suivante,
où j'ai été élue conseillère
municipale de l'opposition
avec deux collègues.
Je suis devenue maire en 1998,
trois ans plus tard,
après la démission
du maire précédent.
-Le maire a démissionné, et là,
des élus de sa propre liste
ont décidé de voter pour vous.
-Tout à fait.
-Vous êtes devenue maire
pendant 19 ans,
puis conseillère régionale,
présidente de l'intercommunalité,
aujourd'hui députée,
mais c'est ce mandat à la tête
d'un village de 300 habitants
que vous avez préféré.
Pourquoi ?
-Parce que la proximité,
pour moi, c'est mon ADN.
Quel est le plus beau mandat
pour un élu que celui de maire,
où on est au contact
des concitoyens tout le temps,
matin, midi et soir ?
Chacun a notre numéro de portable
et on est interpellé
pour toutes les situations,
qu'elles soient sociales
ou d'autres difficultés.
On a aussi
une capacité d'agir
extrêmement rapide.
-Oui.
-Quand on prend des décisions
dans une commune de 350 habitants,
on peut quasiment l'appliquer
le lendemain matin.
-Pas quand on est députée.
-Ce n'est pas le cas
dans ma mission d'aujourd'hui,
effectivement.
-C'est donc un drame qui est
à l'origine de votre engagement
en politique, et quand on regarde
les sujets qui vous mobilisent,
on voit que la montagne est partout.
Vous avez d'ailleurs présidé
l'ANEM, l'Association nationale
des élus de la montagne.
Vous présentez cette association
comme le Parti de la montagne.
C'est-à-dire que quand on est élu
de montagne,
il y a plus de droite,
de gauche, de centre ?
On défend tous...
-Les combats de la montagne
sont transpartisans.
Effectivement, ce que j'ai beaucoup
aimé dans cette association,
c'était vraiment
d'avoir un rassemblement d'élus,
quel que soit leur bord politique,
qui portent les mêmes valeurs,
et la même défense
de ces territoires de montagne,
et la défense
de la spécificité montagnarde,
qui est un sujet important
pour les gens qui y vivent,
qui est vraiment difficile
à faire entendre à l'Assemblée.
Ca fait 13 ans que je suis députée,
et j'ai l'impression que je rabâche
de manière permanente
que la spécificité de la montagne
doit être considérée,
ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas.
-En 2007 : nouvelle étape,
dans votre engagement,
avec Didier Migaud,
qui vous a proposé
de devenir sa suppléante.
Trois ans plus tard,
Didier Migaud
a été nommé à la présidence
de la Cour des comptes.
Il a fallu trouver quelqu'un,
au sein du PS,
pour lui succéder,
le Parti Socialiste vous a choisie.
Vous vous y attendiez pas du tout.
Pourquoi ?
Vous vous projetiez pas
dans ce mandat-là, de députée ?
-La petite anecdote,
c'est que quand j'ai accepté
d'être la suppléante
de Didier Migaud,
j'étais surprise qu'il vienne,
à l'époque, me solliciter,
et je lui avais dit :
"Ne sois jamais ministre
"parce que je ne souhaite
pas être députée."
Trois ans après,
il a tenu son engagement,
il n'a pas été ministre.
-C'était un cas de figure
que vous aviez pas anticipé.
-Pas du tout.
Il a dû démissionner.
La question s'est posée
de comment...
Qui pour lui succéder ?
J'ai donc eu une semaine
pour réfléchir.
Est-ce que je m'engage
dans ce mandat
qui était pas prévu pour moi ?
Est-ce que j'ai assez de temps
et de capacité pour m'y investir ?
L'aventure
était sûrement trop belle à tenter.
J'ai accepté de le faire
et j'ai été soutenue, effectivement,
par le Parti Socialiste,
car à l'époque,
je n'étais pas socialiste,
c'était pas une condition
que m'avait posée Didier Migaud
pour partir avec lui
dans cette aventure.
-Vous avez été élue, réélue.
Vous-même,
vous avez dû choisir un suppléant.
Les liens
entre un député et son suppléant
peuvent être forts,
mais la politique
est faite de trahisons.
Vous avez connu cela en 2017,
on était à un mois des législatives,
quand votre suppléant,
non seulement a changé de bord,
il a rejoint Emmanuel Macron,
mais il s'est présenté face à vous.
Comment on se remet
d'un coup pareil ?
-D'abord, on est un peu surpris,
un peu sous le choc de se dire :
"Bon, s'il me l'avait dit
six mois ou un an avant,
"je me sens plus bien au sein
du Parti Socialiste
"et j'envisage de rejoindre
Emmanuel Macron",
bon, bah très bien.
Chacun fait sa voie.
Là, ça a été quand même
assez soudain.
J'y étais pas forcément préparée,
et puis on n'avait pas beaucoup
de temps
pour trouver un autre suppléant
et se relancer dans cette dynamique,
- ça coupe la dynamique,
quand même -
et de se relancer
dans cette campagne.
Nous avons relevé le défi.
Aujourd'hui, j'ai un suppléant
fidèle, qui m'accompagne,
et voilà, les choses sont passées,
mais c'est vrai que la politique
est parfois difficile.
-Ca a failli
vous coûter votre siège
à l'Assemblée.
Au soir du 1er tour
de cette élection,
votre ancien suppléant
avait 14 points d'avance sur vous.
Tout le monde pensait
qu'il allait gagner
au 2nd tour et vous l'avez emporté
avec huit points d'avance.
Plusieurs élus de droite
avaient appelé
à voter pour vous
dans l'entre-deux-tours.
Diriez-vous
que c'est ce que vous appelez
le Parti de la montagne
qui vous a aidée à remporter
cette élection ?
-Oui,
je crois que c'est un peu ça.
Ca a fait partie
de cette réussite collective.
J'ai l'habitude de dire
que cette campagne
a été la plus difficile,
de par ces événements,
mais aussi la plus belle,
parce que c'était
une victoire collective,
avec un rassemblement
d'élus et de citoyens
qui étaient pas forcément
de mon camp politique,
mais qui ont voulu marquer le fait
que ça ne se fait pas d'avoir
un comportement comme ça
à la dernière minute.
Les montagnards
se sont aussi mobilisés.
Textuellement, un élu m'a dit :
"C'est pas possible,
"on ne peut pas perdre
nos députés de montagne."
Il y a eu une forte mobilisation.
-Ils se retrouvaient
dans les combats
que vous avez menés.
-Et puis la proximité avec laquelle
je traitais les sujets
de manière régulière.
Donc je suis passée, effectivement,
de 19 % au 1er tour à 58 au 2e tour,
ce qui est un grand saut.
-Depuis 2022,
vous siégez dans une Assemblée
qui n'a pas de majorité absolue,
une Assemblée plus agitée
que les précédentes.
Il y a beaucoup de députés
et de ministres
qui parlent même de "bordélisation".
Pourquoi vous vous en plaignez pas ?
-C'est pas que je m'en plains pas.
Il y a des moments
qui sont difficiles.
Je trouve plus d'intérêt à ce mandat
que le mandat précédent,
puisqu'il y avait
une tellement forte majorité
que la parole de l'opposition
était réduite à néant.
Là, on a quand même
une capacité à agir,
lorsque la majorité
recherche une majorité,
effectivement.
-Vous avez créé votre entreprise
de transports peu après
votre candidature aux municipales.
Vous en êtes restée la patronne,
y compris après votre élection
à l'Assemblée.
On vous voit au volant
d'un de vos autocars.
C'est compliqué de gérer
une entreprise en étant députée ?
-Oui, c'est extrêmement difficile.
A l'époque, j'étais maire
de La Salle-en-Beaumont aussi,
car il y avait pas la loi
sur le non-cumul des mandats,
mais lorsque je suis arrivée
en 2010,
ça faisait trois ans
que je m'étais lancée
dans cette aventure
d'entreprise de transports
avec un associé.
J'étais censée être élue
pour deux années,
donc je me suis dit...
-Il fallait un filet de sécurité.
-Voilà.
Et puis en 2012,
après avoir vu pendant deux ans
ce qui se passait à l'Assemblée,
et voir un certain nombre d'élus
qui me paraissaient déconnectés
de la réalité
et du quotidien des gens,
je me suis dit
que c'était important pour moi
de garder cette entreprise,
de garder cette activité,
de voir le salarié
le lundi matin ou le vendredi,
et de rester ancrée dans le concret
du monde économique.
Du coup, j'ai fait ce choix,
alors que j'aurais pu évidemment
arrêter de travailler.
-La députée
conduisait régulièrement l'autocar ?
-Oui,
je faisais du transport scolaire.
Les enfants étaient d'un calme plat.
-Ils devaient être impressionnés
de voir une députée.
-C'est arrivé très régulièrement.
-Vous avez créé l'entreprise
car vous n'avez pas le tempérament
pour travailler pour les autres.
On peut comprendre
que ça corresponde à votre goût
pour ce mandat de maire,
mais quand on est députée,
n'est-ce pas plus compliqué
d'avoir ce tempérament-là ?
-Je pense que c'est bon
d'avoir du tempérament.
Nous, dans notre parti,
nous avons la dépendance
de position,
lorsqu'il y a vraiment un sujet
qui nous tient à coeur
et qui ne fait pas partie
de la ligne politique globale
de l'ensemble de notre groupe.
On a cette liberté
de pouvoir à la fois s'exprimer
et donner sa position
à titre personnel.
Donc moi, je trouve ma place
de manière très facile,
au sein du groupe
dans lequel je siège,
mais c'est vrai que je suis
assez indépendante de tempérament
et lorsque je suis
dans un travail ou une mission
qui ne me convient plus,
je préfère partir
plutôt que de mal le faire.
-On va passer au quiz.
Vous allez devoir compléter
trois phrases
que je vais vous proposer.
On commence par :
entre montagnards à l'Assemblée...
-"Entre montagnards à l'Assemblée" ?
-Entre élus de montagne,
pas montagnards.
-Il y a une espèce de connivence,
de complicité
et de partage des mêmes convictions,
et comme je le disais
tout à l'heure,
une action collective.
-Vous retrouvez
le dépassement des clivages,
y compris dans l'hémicycle.
Faire de la politique,
c'est comme conduire un autocar...
-Il y a des risques.
On l'a vu tout à l'heure.
C'est une fonction,
puisque là,
on est sur une fonction
plutôt qu'un métier, exigeant.
On n'a pas forcément
le droit à l'erreur,
ni au volant d'un car,
ni à la tribune,
parce que tous nos mots
sont épluchés et commentés,
donc j'ai envie de dire
que c'est deux métiers exigeants.
-Enfin :
le prochain suppléant
qui me trahit...
Qu'est-ce qui lui arrivera ?
-Il y en aura plus,
il a vu que ça ne marchait pas.
Il a vu que ça ne marchait pas.
-Il est averti, le suppléant
que vous avez choisi aujourd'hui ?
-Je pense
qu'il ne me trahira jamais.
Il n'a, comme moi à ce stade,
pas le souhait d'être député,
comme je l'étais précédemment.
-Merci beaucoup d'être venue.
-Merci à vous.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA